all right I need to eliminate gin - and
find anton sokolov
over build something like this and why
ah one that debate is one of the
mechanisms in my house my home is always
open
it's one of my great curiosity has seen
how the common I'm caring gin - but you
must know that before you stands an
invention that will endure beyond my
time the jinn - clockwork soldier marvel
and the clockwork soldiers Honda
metallic skeletons and razor-sharp
blades the miniaturize whale oil tanks
are spread across the frame and hidden
behind protective Ambu panels
visual awareness in the front and bad
auditory detection in case the head unit
sustains catastrophic damage my greatest
creation I invite you to complete
stranger just come up the stairs meet
with me face to face
there you are magnificent
[Music]
now that I see you I worked out if you
are not a hired cutthroat - your clothes
are too fine an aristocratic
thrill-seeker that's closer you trained
with weapons formerly but we're not a
salon fencer is good back alley all that
only one manner award at math tonight
knowledge
welcome royal protector
obviously you're pleased with yourself
you know why I'm here I'd assume my
involvement with the Duke brought you to
my door
well maybe our [ __ ] washed up anton
sokolov comfortably residing in the
assessment chamber I'd away confined me
until whatever is music but if you fall
I'll have your body carrying to my lab
for dissection and study until I learn
come to the pass no secret is safe with
me I'll see you soon Jin - I'm Hilda
[Music]
in part I made this place our luxury and
spectacle I suppose but it's more than
that engineering itself the space beyond
in the walls
ah I sent you I know where you are
you're quite close now I can't remember
any other that are getting so far
and you realize you're only the second
person to set foot in this room the most
sophisticated laboratory in the aisles
please not to damage anything soldiers
intruder
welcome to the final mystery Jin Dodge